so here's a fact worth remembering if
you want to think clearly if you want to
make wise decisions you have to use
clear and precise language here's
another fact
if by contrast you want to brainwash and
control an entire population and the
first thing you do is ban clear language
and substitute it with propaganda that
is nonsensical chunks of words glued
together for political effect
in two sentences that's our entire
current political landscape the left
understands it the right does not
consider the term people of color now
that's a phrase that would have seemed
mildly offensive 20 years ago kind of an
ugly term and yet now it's mandatory to
every level of our society the question
is what does it mean exactly what is a
person of color well it's anyone who
isn't white which is to say it's the
overwhelming majority of the world's
population
so you have to ask yourself how exactly
is this a meaningful category
what does a polynesian tuna fisherman
have in common with a bolivian coca
farmer or a foundry worker in central
china for that matter with kamala harris
well not really anything except that
they're not white
that's a pretty ominous way to define a
huge group of people if you think about
it in fact it's a racist way to define a
huge group of people
everyone who's white is not the same and
only an entitled white liberal could
believe otherwise no normal person could
ever think that so let's stop using the
phrase let's not participate
don't use the term people of color this
is the crudest kind of propaganda
designed to divide the country by race
so don't say it
what do you replace it with if you're
white what do you call people who don't
look like you
well if they're citizens of this country
maybe you call them americans because
that's what they actually are
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else